[موسيقى]
منذ لحظه ولاده شهر شعبان والقمر يسير خلف
الشمس متجها من الغرب الى جهه الشرق
ويحاول بكل جديه ان يدرك الشمس وسيدركها
في تمام الساعه الثامنه واثنين وعشرين
دقيقه من مساء يوم الثلاثه وفي ذلك المساء
سيغرب القمر قبل مغيب الشمس ولم يولد بعد
وحينئذ لا يوجد القمر البته بعد مغيب شمس
يوم الثلاثاء وبعد مغيب شمس يوم الاربعاء
سيكون له مكث قرابه الاربعين دقيقه هذا من
باب التقريب عالميا وعلى هذا الاساس
ستكتمل عده شهر شعبان ثلاثين يوما والخميس
23 23 23
اول ايام شهر رمضان الفضيل ورمضان لهذه
السنه سيبدا في يوم
ينتهي فيه فسيبدا يوم الخميس وينتهي يوم
الخميس ويوم الجمعه اول ايام العيد السعيد
اليوم يوم الجمعه مبارك ما اروعه يوم له
فضائل في ديننا مع رفعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والهلال لا يرى بالعين المجرده او بالعين
المسلحه الا اذا تحققت اركانه وتوافرت
شروطه فله ركنين ان يولد القمر قبل مغيب
الشمس وان يكون للقمر مكث بعد مغيب الشمس
وشروطه ان يخرج من حي شعاع الشمس ومن حيز
الغبار والاتربه
وصفاء الاجواء تم الكلام وربنا محمود وله
المكارم والعلا والجود ثم الصلاه على
النبي محمد ما غرد قمري واورق
عودوا
[موسيقى]